first on CBS this morning Bon Appetit
magazine is revealing this year's list
of the hot ten best new restaurants in
the u.s. deputy editor Andrew Knowlton
and senior projects editor Julia Cramer
sampled food across the country for
nearly a year they traveled a combined
235 thousand miles to visit 41 cities
they landed in 22 different airports to
put together this year's list and we
gave them cameras to document their
journey the hardest place to eat just
because no vegetable goes uncooked
people are definitely looking at me like
I'm a crazy person
typical day for me on the road is to
breakfast if people are always like oh I
want to go to dinner with you your job
sounds so amazing and then they come out
with me and we have one dinner I try to
hit to lunch and then to dinner then I'm
like okay it's time to go to the next
dinner and they're like what that's when
you know if something is really good is
if you can't stop eating it after six
meals I am looking for restaurants that
have a very particular point of view I
think that that is what sets our list
apart from the many other lists that are
now out there we'd like to go from ten
to numero uno when it's time for us to
present our list to our editor-in-chief
Adam Rapoport we make these big boards
where we pray this is all Julia by the
way this is her influence cuz she loves
school I don't think so I mean I might
have like shown him an Instagram from my
phone these are some of her desserts
which are all very like modern looking
we made these big boards and we print
out photos of the food and the chef and
the space and then we go to his office
and we sort of talked him through each
of the ten restaurants and hope that he
gives us the green light it's a really
really small kitchen we go in there with
confidence I think and trust ourselves
that we came up with a list that's
diverse in its cuisine geographically
diverse and it's restaurants that are
representative of what's going on in
American restaurants at this moment and
I think if we hit those places I think
we have a pretty solid list all those
meals and trips led to their hot 10:00
restaurant list they range from classic
comfort food to new American cuisine and
stretch from San Francisco to New York
coming in at number three is mister Jews
in San Francisco number two is el ski in
Chicago and their number one pick is
Turkey and the wolf in New Orleans
Andrew and Julia welcome Nick you care
so why do you give them number one
well Turkey the wolf is this it's a
really weird unexpected choice I think
it's basically a sandwich shop stuff
that we all grew up with a bologna say
which a chicken sandwich but just
elevated and I think what we agreed on
is we had more fun eating at Turkey in
the wolf than any other place it was
that restaurant that both of us couldn't
get out of our mind they do this amazing
collard green melt that sounds so
mundane it's a vegetarian sandwich I
don't really like vegetarian sandwiches
and it was the best thing I ate this
year and it was just you know was
nostalgic it was fun it was escapism for
me well I know I want to look the paint
and lick the page when I look yeah you
guys put in but you it seems like
Chicago is having a moment Julia your
hometown yeah yeah and I not just saying
that because obviously goodbye yeah no I
think Chicago is really emblematic of
the most exciting things that are going
on in food around the country but all
concentrated in this one city this have
an amazing range of diverse types of
restaurants you have incredible Mexican
food incredible Korean food Portuguese
food all sort of coming together with
new spins and that else key you said for
desserts you described as visual
artistry yes yes I love this restaurant
this is number two on our list it's a
husband and wife he does the savory she
does the sweet and her desserts are so
gorgeous yes they are visual artistry
but they also actually taste amazing and
then one for my home my home state
Raleigh North Carolina
yeah brewery Bhuvana you're from
Henderson which is just north of Raleigh
so next time you gotta go I'll be there
so it's just it's a mash-up it's a
flower shop it's a brewery
it's a dim sum place in a bookstore and
it's in this vast space and what does it
become from North Carolina and Raleigh
specifically it's kind of a community
center
it's run by first-generation immigrants
from Laos they've made friends with a
guy who brews beer and it's just this
amazing space for people all different
walks of life can come and the dim sum
is as good as any of had in New York
City one more great thing about
immigrants yes Julia you write that
people are sort of returning to
nostalgia and comfort food yeah so one
of the trends that we saw all over was a
return of dishes like prime rib and ice
cream pie and all this stuff that's what
chefs actually want to eat and now
they're saying hey we don't have to do
the tweezer food thing anymore we can
just cook the food
restaurant with what was it you know all
the chef's kind of like and one example
of that comfort food is in Philadelphia
oh yeah so that's an amazing place
called PO NC social club which is number
four on our list it's a very old-school
Italian American restaurant you can get
you know shells and in red sauce but
it's done by this amazing chef who's
putting like a little bit of a modern
fresh twist and the one thing about this
place is you have to have a membership
to get in anybody can buy a membership
you just have to get there right when
they open pay twenty bucks you get a
membership for the year
then you can eat there anytime you want
and you divide up the country how do you
decide where you're gonna go between the
two of you and do the restaurants know
you're coming ahead of time so the
restaurants do not know that we are
coming we yeah I use you know fake names
I use all kinds of old baseball players
that nobody will recognize anything I
can think of and then we divide it up
just you know year to year I went to the
Pacific Northwest West Coast that was
for a reason that we'll probably get to
in a second
Julia did the East Coast and we just
kind of crisscross two mouths are always
better than one I think when you're
trying to eat it you'll get Instagram
feeds or ideas from people that tell you
you should go here yeah we spend the
whole year researching these restaurants
we look at their instagrams we talked to
friends in those cities we read all the
local news to try to figure out which
ones are worth going to and my favorite
part of this whole story too is that
Julia was pregnant through this whole
thing to me like I said mad respek
because this is a hard job no I have a
food baby she's had two babies
he has mad respect no it's not me
pregnant and do all that yeah well but
not drinking definitely kept me on track
but not only do you find these great
restaurants it's beautifully written
it's you know fun read so proud of it to
both of you Andrew Knowlton and Julia
Kramer thanks again you to find out more
about these top restaurants visit cBS
This Morning Calm